hi there steve kaufman here again uh to
talk about you know starting to speak
all right
uh first of all if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe
okay i've been learning greek i think
i've been at it for two months
mostly listening and reading no mostly
exclusively listening and reading
mostly listening to these mini stories
which i've listened to each one of them
i don't know how many times and read
them
and so i decided i would start to speak
now we don't have any greek tutors at
link so i went to italki as i have done
before
as i've done for polish for ukrainian
for korean no not for korean
at any rate
um so i had my first uh 30 minutes with
uh greek first time i've actually
looked at a greek person and spoken
greek
it was difficult
and that's what i want to get into here
difficult for a variety of reasons first
of all as with most well-meaning tutors
the tutor insists on explaining things
in english and it takes a lot of effort
to persuade them
that in fact you don't want to hear i
don't want to hear english explanations
i want to struggle through in greek so
i'm hoping that that situation improved
and then of course the well-meaning
tutors they want to know well shall i
send you a pdf on greek grammar or a
list of
all the english words that have greek
origins and stuff and maybe but i can
find those myself what i really want is
to try to speak in greek and to have him
and i think i got that message across
write up a list of 10 or 15 words and
phrases that cause me difficulty so that
i can then review them and hopefully do
better the second time
as an experience of course i failed
miserably
uh words that i can easily remember when
i walk around the house trying to
rehearse what i might say
once i'm confronted with a real live
person
and there's a little pressure
i can't remember the words i don't know
where they went to
sometimes my brain heads down some
slavic path to pull some word up
that doesn't belong of course
so it's very difficult
but i know this uh and typically in most
languages i would normally wait
much longer before speaking i think i
waited a year with russian i waited six
months with check
whenever you do start speaking you're
going to struggle
um
so
and and it's important to realize that
you actually have to speak a lot to
become good at speaking it's just a
question of when you start
uh typically i prefer like i've got two
months now
in me i've got according to my
statistics at link i have
some 1700 words that i
at least know when i see them
and i got another 4 000 or so that i've
saved some of them i know some of them i
don't know
so i've got some vocabulary
theoretically if i were able to recall
everything that i've learned i would
have been able to
speak i think my pronunciation is quite
good because i've listened so much
but eventually i have to speak a lot so
i had to look at my statistics in
russian
where i've done most of my
speaking
maybe not most but a lot of my speaking
with our tutors at link i have a
statistic i have spoken 179 hours of
russia just that link that's not
counting other conversations that i've
had so i've spoken a lot even in in
czech i think it's 30 hours at link and
yet i did most of my uh speaking in
czech outside link with tutors that i
found on the internet
um
yeah you have to speak many many hours
so i'm not at all discouraged in fact my
goal in this is
uh because i know that speaking however
badly you speak
the goal is not to do well the goal is
to to force yourself to try to remember
things to see where things are missing
to stimulate the brain a bit so that
when i go back now
to my listening and reading
i'm even more focused
and one thing i started doing now after
seeing how that conversation went was
i'm doing a little more uh reading out
loud so it's as if i'm pretending to be
speaking
and so we'll see how all of this goes
i'm speaking to the same tutor again
tomorrow this time it's an hour uh i'm
hoping that we can keep it all in greek
uh i don't mind struggling and i think
it's very good when the tutor
hears you lets you struggle a bit and
then sort of summarizes what you've said
and starts using the words that you
wanted to use
uh that's a lot better than giving you
the english
and so in this way slowly you start to
you know drag up
the stuff that you know you've been
putting in your brain
uh through all of this uh this input
um
[Music]
i should say under normal circumstances
if it weren't for the fact that i'm
going to crete in october
uh i wouldn't be in any great hurry i'm
enjoying my listening and reading uh
we've got now i think 40 uh greek
lessons
of the mini story series
uh in our library at link it's further
ahead than the others because i'm
actually paying someone to translate and
record for me i'm not waiting for all
the volunteers
uh
so
and and now i've done them all
and i can't wait for the next story
because it's fun to plow through and
look up new words and so forth we have
some texts that are
more difficult quite a bit more
difficult you know newspaper articles
and political articles and there i can
make my way through it by looking up all
the words but
there's no fluency there and there's
just too many words too many new words i
haven't got a hope of remembering them
so so i am hoping to get more of these
simple stories that i can continue to
use where there's a lot of repetition in
each story i'm able to listen to them
many times read them many times and and
gradually build myself up so there you
have it getting started it's always a
struggle but i much prefer doing it when
at least i have a hope of understanding
what the other person is saying i have
at least
the feeling that i should be able to
find some words because i have some
words
and so
in this case i've started after say two
months of an hour or so a day of of
greek learning uh
with czech it was six months
with romanian it was after one month
because i was going to romania i had to
do it but with romanian again there's so
many words that are similar to italian
that it was a lot easier with greek it's
uh it's more difficult so we will see
how it goes thank you for listening uh
bye for now oh and i'm gonna mention by
the way
i will do a separate video
about the lawn fest the lang
language festival festival de long in
montreal
uh a great place for people to meet
people who are learning on their own or
learning schools
and i should point out and i'll point
this out again when i do this dedicated
video that anyone who registers at the
montreal language festival and uses as a
code name steve not at all case
sensitive sure you know small letters
big letter capital letter it doesn't
matter steve you'll get a 25 discount in
fact there's a whole range of discounts
that you're entitled to so
uh i'm hoping to see you
in montreal in august i'm going to be in
blatislava in
[Music]
the
language or the polyglot conference
there end of may early june
so and that's it for today thank you bye
for now
[Music]
you